hemos visto un montón de veces y
seguramente ya estás hasta cansado de
que te lo diga pero es muy importante
volver a decir que esta área que tengo
aquí justo de color amarillo esta área
que está por encima del eje x desde el
punto x igual am hasta el punto x igual
a ver a esta la podemos denotar con esta
expresión que tengo aquí como la
integral definida desde am hasta ver de
fx de x ahora bien lo que quiero ver en
este vídeo y de lo cual estoy muy seguro
que tú podrías obtener la respuesta por
tu cuenta de una manera muy fácil pero
bueno en este vídeo lo quiero ver de una
manera muy intuitiva es bueno empezar
con el área bajo la curva de una versión
escalada de fx
imagínate que me tomo para empezar james
es igual a una constante por fx es decir
que es igual a una versión escalada por
fx a un número que multiplica a fx y
bueno es que realmente se puede valer
cualquier numerito que a ti se te ocurra
y de hecho am para hacerlo más fácil voy
a pensar que se vale 3 si se vale 3
entonces como
esta gráfica bueno pues aquí tendría el
triple de distancia am se vería más o
menos así aquí tengo una vez a dos veces
tres veces empezaría como por aquí más o
menos a amd si yo tengo esta distancia
de que hasta acá ok
esta distancia de que ésta cada bueno
habrá que hacerla tres veces bien pues
sería a una por acá ok y después tenemos
más o menos como por aquí ok más o menos
y si me fijo justo aquí como tendría la
versión de tres veces f x aquí es una
vez y después hubo otra vez y otra vez y
más o menos voy a estar como por acá ok
de lujo y si ahora me fijo por ejemplo
en esta distancia de kim ok en esta
distancia de aquí tengo una vez y si la
repito tres veces me quedaría algo más o
menos como por aquí a ok seré la segunda
vez y por acá sería a más o menos la
tercera vez estaría como justo por aquí
es decir que si yo pinto tres veces f x
se va a ver más o menos así vamos a
subir hasta acá ok vamos a llegar a este
punto
ok y después vamos a llegar justo por
acá y después vamos a empezar a bajar
estás de acuerdo se va a ver más o menos
así
va a bajar un poco como por acá ok más o
menos así y después ante m
triplicar esta distancia aquí tengo una
estaría por acá dos por acá tendría como
la tercera estás de acuerdo entonces más
o menos se vería así más o menos es una
aproximación se vería así am la gráfica
de tres veces
fx se va a ver más o menos así digo
solamente es una aproximación así que
déjame poner que esta de aquí es la
gráfica de c veces fx claro pensando en
ser positiva y distinta de 0 pero ahora
en lo que quiero que te fijes es en cuál
va a ser el área que yo tengo debajo de
esta curva c veces fx desde a hasta b es
decir fíjate bien en esta área que voy a
dibujar aquí am si yo me fijo aquí ok en
esta y después bajó por acá ok por acá
ok más o menos así y ahora me fijo en
toda esta área todo esto todo esto que
estoy coloreando justo ahorita todo esto
ok y yo quisiera saber cuánto vale esta
área que me podría responder y bueno hay
que tener cuidado seguramente lo primero
que
es como se denota esta área tú no puedes
decir ah es que esta área de aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que la integral ok
desde a hasta ver de bueno
esta función de morado es decir c veces
fx de x c veces
fx de x sin embargo quiero tener cuidado
con mi pregunta mi pregunta significaba
lo siguiente cómo está relacionada esta
área que acabo de pintar de color verde
con esta área original con la que
empezamos hace rato es decir con el área
de color amarillo que tengo justo aquí
abajo como están relacionadas estas dos
áreas o dicho de otra manera como está
relacionada esta integral que acabo de
obtener con mi integral original
y bueno una forma de ver esto es que si
tú escalas la dimensión vertical por cm
y esta es una forma de razonar la anp
déjame ser más claro si tú tienes el
área de algo imagínate de un rectángulo
déjame poner aquí a un rectángulo este
de aquí va a ser un rectángulo original
ok y supongamos que mi dimensión
vertical es am no quiero poner a nivel
así que voy a poner desde alfa ok alfa
mientras que mi dimensión horizontal va
a ser beta beta ok
como sacamos el área de este rectángulo
que tengo aquí bueno pues es muy fácil
es lo mismo que alza por beta ok y bueno
ahora qué pasa si escalo la dimensión
vertical
imagínate que ahora me tomo cbc salva
así que por acá por acá voy a poner a
algo así y esto de aquí va a ser ce
veces
alfa veces alfa ok mientras que en mi
dimensión horizontal la voy a mantener
exactamente igual así que ambos de
llegar hasta acá
hasta acá ok más o menos estamos como
por acá y bueno
déjeme déjame poner esté aquí ok
entonces mi dimensión horizontal se
mantiene y es beta quiero que te des
cuenta que lo único que hice fue
multiplicar esta longitud por cm es
decir tomarme veces alta ahora en este
momento te voy a preguntar cuánto vale
esta área y tú me vas a decir bueno es
muy fácil solamente hay que multiplicar
esto por esto lo cual es cbc es ok alfa
por beta alfa por beta bueno hubo otra
forma de ver exactamente lo mismo es la
siguiente yo empecé con un área justo
aquí y cuando yo escalo una de estas
dimensiones voy a obtener la versión
escalada de esa misma área es decir a
veces alza por beta y de hecho es justo
lo que estamos haciendo estamos
escalando la dimensión vertical por se
recuerda que fx lo que nos daba era la
dimensión vertical y la estamos
multiplicando por cm es decir estamos
escalando la altura de esta función y
date cuenta que la equis no cambia si
nosotros regresamos a la idea de sumas
de riman
nos estamos tomando el área de los
rectángulos que tienen el mismo ancho
pero ahora estamos escalando el árbol
porque recuerda que fx lo que nos daba
era la altura de nuestros rectángulos y
ahora lo que estamos haciendo se
escalando esa altura eso quiere decir
que si nosotros vemos a la integral a la
integral desde amd hasta b de c veces fx
efe de x de x es decir estamos pensando
en esta área de color verde esto va a
ser exactamente igual a tomarnos el área
original es decir esta integral tomarnos
esta área de color amarillo déjame
buscar el mismo color me voy a tomar la
integral desde am hasta b de fx de fx de
x es decir estoy pensando en mi integral
original ok pero estoy tomándome una
versión escalada estoy tomándome una
versión escalada de esta función y por
lo tanto me estoy tomando la versión
escalada de esta área o dicho otra
manera de esta integral y justo a este
resultado quería llegar
seguramente tú me puedes decir es que
esta no es una prueba rigurosa basados
en la definición de integrales definidas
pero lo que sí quiero que veas es que es
una forma intuitiva de entender esta
propiedad
tengo enlace adentro de la integral y
ahora puedo sacar las de afuera de la
integral y eso es bastante intuitivo y
es que lo importante de este vídeo es
que recuerda es lo siguiente si yo
escalo
nuestra función original es decir estoy
multiplicando por sea f x eso quiere
decir que estoy escalando la dimensión
vertical
estoy multiplicando a la dimensión
vertical por cm
entonces el área escalada que nos da
esto va a ser exactamente igual a la
versión escalada de esta área original
que teníamos de nuestra función
fx y bueno con esto acabamos de probar
una de las propiedades más importantes
que tenemos ante las integrales esta de
aquí aunque por cierto nos va a ayudar
muchísimo a resolver varios problemas
sobre integrales y también para que
tengas una idea más clara
todo lo que estamos haciendo ok
hasta luego